[Music]
welcome tonight we're going to go
through basic some basic chesa endings
taken from the cherished book of chests
written in 1935 he has a whole section
on endings we're going to take a chapter
on poun endings first King and pawn
versus King they there are some
surprising tricks that you need to know
about to handle these properly then I
think we'll have time to get into work
and pawn endings basically a working
pawn and King versus King and work and
the author Tarrasch says that these can
be the most some of the most difficult
endings in awe of chess so we'll start
with the simpler King and pawn endings
so here's our first example I get rid of
the solution wait to play and win this
is a winning position but it has to be
done properly
now the obviously the White King and
pawn have to advance up to the board and
the pawn has to go to f8 and become a
queen to win and for the pawn to get to
f8 the White King has to be either at g7
or e 7 to protect the f8 square so the
pawn can go to the eight score protected
and become a queen so the f8 square
that's called the queening square now
what you need to know rather than have
our audience guests at it let me state
the principle the principle is that the
the king with the pawn has to be in
front of the passed pawn to win if the
King is behind the pawned the game
becomes a stalemate
when the King and pawn advance as far as
they can the black Kings blocks the pawn
from the eighth-ranked
the White King protects the pawn from
the six rank it takes there are no
squares for the black King to move it
becomes a stalemate
so the solution the mistake that would
be made would be 1f for moving the pawn
first the correct move is to move the
King in front of the pawn you only move
the King at the pawn after you get your
king advanced far enough along so the
right move is King to g2 which will do
here now black is going to has to block
the past pawn his moves are very simple
he's just gonna move over in front of
the pawn so he moves King to g7 is the
direct routes white moves up to the
third rank beside the pond not in front
of it yet black moves up and to block
the White King from going beyond the
fourth rank white King moves up and
noticed that the Kings have one square
between them that's called the
Opposition in chess the person who has
to move is at the disadvantage it's
blacks move black can't move forward you
see because the white king guards the
three squares in front of the black King
the black King either has to move
backwards are to the side that's a
concession in chess
now obviously the King doesn't want to
move backwards because that would give
white could advance his King to the
fifth row equally obvious the black King
will not move to the h-file
because he wants to stay in front of the
past pawn
so the only move that makes sense for
black is King to f6 now it would be a
mistake white is not does not have his
King far enough advanced yet to move his
pawn up so the correct move is the King
move to take the opposition again and
force the black King to either side of
the passed pawn now we have a real
concession once that happens so King to
f4
now black could move back that's what
white wants if black moves back we just
advance and take the opposition again
now blacks choice and it doesn't matter
which way he goes because he loses
either way he either goes to the left or
right so he either goes to e6 or g6 it
doesn't matter so he goes to g6 notice
that we can now advance our King to the
5th row by moving to the left of the
black King see how we're making headway
and we're preparing the path for the
pawn to advance toward the 8th file so
King to e5 notice that the black King
cannot approach the past pawn because we
can advance their pawn to squares with
check force and the King can't go
forward because our past pawn would go
past the King and become a queen so the
King would have to move back to g6 and
then we can move our King up 1 square to
e6 taking the opposition in this case
it's side by side opposition its lateral
opposition and blacks King would have to
move back to g7 so black has to give way
his
his best try is to stay in front of the
passed pawn is probably King to f7 let's
see what Blackjacks okay he goes step 7
now we're on the fifth row we're far
enough advanced we could move our past
pawn up two squares but the easier way
to win is to take the opposition again
forcing black back once more so that's
what we do now again see how we push but
black back now black can go to either
side couple moves ago he was on the
sixth rank in had to give way now we
pushed him to the seventh and he has to
give way now he goes to the to the left
or to east 7 so we can advance our King
to g6 to the right which we do now if he
advances his King up 1 square we advance
our pawn two squares and take away the 5
square from the King and then we can
move our pawn to f5 check forcing the
King back
so if black takes the lateral opposition
of White's King it doesn't do him any
good because we move our past pawn now
see how our King is basically three rows
once
well actually four rows in front of the
pawn but the pawn catches up quick
because he moves the two squares for his
first move so black dropped back to stay
in front of the past pawn now we can
grab the opposition black has to go to
one side or the other but see blacks now
back against the furthest corner now we
can't really we can't go to e7 and guard
the the f8 Square yet because their
pawns not close enough or the black King
could go to g7 and then move up and stop
the pawn so now it's time to advance the
pawn
so we take the two squares notice that
we have another move by the pawn so
black can move to over one square taking
the opposition and remember white moves
so white would have to give way except
for the fact we don't move the King we
move the pawn up that changes that makes
black move White has the opposition
black has to give way our pawn is within
reach of our King on g7 or East 7 we
advance our king and we guard the Queen
in square we just March our pawn up and
get it Queen so the King blocks this is
the best move but it doesn't do black
any good see how we do the pawn move and
it switches now black has to move White
has the opposition black has to give way
to one side or the other then we get our
King up and when we started out we said
we had to get the King to e7 or g7 to
guard the f8 square now we've done that
and there's no way black and stop the
pawns from becoming a queen and it's an
easy checkmate so the principle to keep
in mind you want the King not just one
square in front of the pawn preferably
two squares that gives you two pawn
moves to play with to get the opposition
back if Black gets in front of your king
now in this case remember I said the key
idea would be if the King was one or two
squares in front of the well had a space
between the pawn and the King here there
is none so that there's no pawn move to
give white for white to get a temple say
it's White's move
he asked to give way black has the
opposition white has to go to the left
or the
right and then black can block him again
now if it's if it was blacks move white
would have the opposition and black
would have to give way and white would
win easily if it's blacks move let's say
black move King to g7 what's the winning
move for white feel free to chime in
King e6 and then you see black is
nothing better than moving his King to
f8 and we move our King too over to f6
take the opposition and force him aside
then we grab the queening square the
answer is though white wins it depends
on whose move it is if it's blacks move
white wins cuz white would have the
opposition and black would have to give
way on the other hand if it's White's
move it's a draw so let's we know we've
gone through the winds let's go through
the draw okay so the draw would go like
this King here black takes the
opposition see we can't advance our King
and force black Pat back to the first
row do you see that so we have nothing
and if we go back in front of the bond
he just moves this King in front and we
repeat the position over and over again
which would be a draw so they only try
is to move the pawn up now
let's me think the correct move is to
move in front of the pond see we don't
let the White King get in front of the
pond now now if the White King moves
back we just moved the black king to f6
so the pond has to go up
now there's only one defensive move for
black he moves he has to move straight
back because if white moves the king up
black has to take the opposition you see
that now if white goes to the left side
it doesn't make any sense black king
moves up next to the pawn f7 and
threatens King takes pawn forcing white
to go back so to advance white does the
check now the king moves over and to the
only move to protect the pawn is to move
here and notice that white just took
away all blacks moves black can't move
its draw by stalemate that is what
happens if you don't have your king at
least to want to cut one square in front
of that you can be in front of the pawn
if it's your opponent's move if it's
your move the pawn has to be one square
be two scores behind the King so that
you can waste a move with the pawn and
that changes the move to black to move
and he has to give way now this is a
little bit like our last example but
everything has been moved up one row so
the white King is now on the six and the
pawn is on the fifth remember when and
the black King is back on the 8th now
remember we just went over it we said
whoever move it depended on
moved if black had to move white one
if white had to move it was a draw now
if this is the same it would logically
mean that if black had to move he would
lose so let's say black moves to e8 we
can take the queening square away from
black by King to g7 and then we just
move our pawn up three scores that's a
simple win now let's look at White's
move the question is is is it a draw or
a win for white anyone have an opinion
on that white to move is it a win or
draw a win you're right let's look at it
the King moves here black moves here
pawn moves here King has to go here now
we advance the pawn and look the pawn
guards the square it in front of the
white king the e8 square so the black
King can't take the opposition the black
king is forced to give way to the side
of the board giving up the coining
square and we advance and we get the
Queen and checkmate so the answer is
that the fact that the starting position
is up one square the King on the sixth
upon white wins no matter whose move it
is now this one is simpler
it's a rook pawn who knows the rule work
pawns are often draws who knows the rule
for a draw what's the rule black king is
where it's a draw
the corners a draw but he doesn't even
have to be in the corner
what square does he have to be on to be
a draw all he has to get to is the f8
square one squared to the left now he's
one square to the right which is even
better for black in the corner like you
said is even better because with a rook
pawn the white king can't go around to
the other side and force the king out of
the corner so the move goes King to h8
now if the White King moves anywhere the
black king moves up and attacks the pawn
white can't make any progress and if he
advances the rook pawn it's an immediate
stalemate there are no moves for a black
King to get out of the corner hi here's
another rook pawn now remember I said
the black King had to be to the bishop
file f8 was the first example but it
works on the Queen side but it would be
c8 but he can't get to c8 notice that
the white king blocks the past pawn
right the only way white can be get a
queen is if he can move his king to the
right allowing the pawn to advance
correct so the defense that draws is to
move the black king in opposition to the
white king so the King can't move over
to the right side so the correct move is
king here notice that the white king
can't go to b7 b6 or b5 he can only
advance and now we can maintain the
opposition we move our king up see we
follow him up and down and he can never
move away from in front of his pawn
and so it's a draw that's this is the
other way to get a draw with the rook
pawn so he advances the pawn we go to
the c8 square he advances the King we go
here he advances the pawn we go up there
now that White King is still mated the
King can't move at all on the pawn can't
move it's a draw by stalemate this is a
different example altogether
the purpose of this example is the
question is whose move is it white or
black let's say it's White's move now
the white king is in the corner and is
blocked by the black King so the white
King cannot help the pawn the only
question is can that pawn advance to the
g8 Square and become a queen before the
black king can stop it now there's two
so we're only talking about pawn the
white pawn moving straight ahead move
after move and black King moving along
the diagonal to try to intercept it
there's two ways to calculate this the
first is counting the moves let's count
the white moves the first move would be
pawn to g4 one and then it would go up
two three four five it takes five moves
for white to get it Queen now let's
count how many moves when the white pawn
gets to g7 threatening g8 Queen the
black King has to move to f7 where it
guards the Queen e square see that how
many moves does it take the black King
to get to f7 so we count those so let's
go b4 one
see five 2d six 3e seven four f75 so
they takes five moves for both sides
but remember whites fifth move white
moves first and his fifth move is to get
a queen when white makes the fifth move
blacks King isn't close enough so let's
walk through it so that's one each two
two three three four
you see we're ready to Queen and black
is a move short even though it was both
five because white moved first black
doesn't have time okay now if blacks
move now black moves has five moves but
he goes first so now he can stop the
pawn he moves his King here here two two
three three four four and we make our
fifth move because black moved first and
he stops the pawn that's counting moves
there's an easier technique a geometric
technique where you don't have to count
moves at all the way it is there's
called the square and it's named after a
German chess master who discovered this
technique called Berger squares name was
Berger you take the pawn and you go
straight up to the queening Square to g8
that's one part of the square or you
take the pawn and you take that diagonal
f-4e v d6 c7 b8 and you make a square
and it comes back next to the black king
you see the corner is on b3 so you see
that imaginary square the pawn makes the
rule is if black can move into the
square he can stop the pawn now because
the square goes from g3 to g8 to b8 to
b3 the black King can enter the square
either on b3 or b4 and stop the pawn so
if you know the square rule you don't
have to count the moves but you need to
know how to count moves because
sometimes your there are other endings
and the square rule doesn't apply but
you can always count moves so it's
helpful in County moves is helpful in
almost every ending okay so anyway
that's that and it's important to know
that square rule the the principle is
see how there are two past white pawns
and only one black pawn now notice that
the white king can easily stop the black
pawn from becoming a queen because the
king is in the black pawn square
only if it's White's move because the
black pawn can move two squares right
and his first move would be h5 so we
have to make the square from h5 and oh
okay
it can run down to D see how it runs
down to d1 and h1 so the white King can
enter the square white white doesn't
have to move to stop the pawn he just
moves his King over but when white moves
his King over
that'll leave his pawn on c3 unprotected
and it looks like black can take that
pawn on c3 and then move over and take
the pawn on h2 for a draw but there's a
technique when you have to pass pawns
separated by a file you can move the
pawns up so that the opposing king can't
take either pause so the pawns actually
can defend each other even though
they're not in contact with each other
so let's look and see how that works to
do it correctly you have to move the
backward pawn up two squares now notice
what that did black moves his pawn up
and the White King leaves the c3 pawn
the black King though can't take the c3
pawn because he would be behind the a4
pawn which could advance to become a
queen see that that's how the two pawns
defend each other by moving up and when
the King goes to one side the other pawn
has to advance and then the King can't
take it because it would run to be a
queen so we'll see this pattern black
moves his pawn the King has to come over
and stop it
okay so the King gets there just in time
to stop the black pawn now you see that
black could take the pawn but then he
can't stop the a pawn from advance
because his King would be behind the
pawn you see that and he can't catch it
so the King has to move back from the c3
pawn which he does we move our King next
to that pond we're gonna kill off the
black pawn as soon as we can
now the King goes here and black
threatens to get a draw by King to a5
attacking the a4 pawn taking that pawn
then he can come and get the c3 pawn now
this is how the top pawns protect each
other the backward pawn advances see
that now
whichever pawn the King attacks the
other pawn moves up and the King can't
take the backward pawn because the other
pawn would become a queen so in this
case he goes King to a5 now we advance
the pawn and notice the king can't take
the a4 pawn that gives the White King a
temple to kill off the black pawn which
he does black now goes in front of the
advanced pawn so now that you know the
pattern what's the winning move for
white here a5 exactly right Matt and now
the past same pattern what's the move
right so the King go now we can bring
our king over to support one of the past
pawn on c5 and we'll get our Queen
and it's even worse here because the
king is now can't even get in run of the
pawn so we don't even have to get the
King over there we're gonna get the
Queen next move so so if you ever find
yourself with two deaths disconnected
pawns like against one you have an
opportunity to win the game so you need
to remember that principle white has an
obvious advantage a protected past pawn
there's no the only question is can
black draw the game or not the short
answer is black is lost but there's an
ending trick that white has to use to
win the game let's say well the key the
white King can obviously advance to f6
and try to come around the right side
and then force the black King back so
the the obvious move is king to f6 so
let's let's do that move now blacks
trying to hold the draw what is blacks
best move to try to hold the draw d8 is
better now remember you if you're
defending or attacking you want to take
the opposition ordinarily the opposition
is one King in front of the other or
side by side
that's called vertical side by side is
lateral they have diagonal in this case
black King took diagonal opposition
that's the best move let's show what
happens if he doesn't because it's a
very simple win let's say he goes over
here
then we see how we grab the opposition
we force him over now we advance the
pawn and he can't stop the Queen and
it's checkmate in a couple moves but
look how difficult it is if he makes the
right move
now let's say we come this way
what's his move now
he ate he takes the opposition and we
check him he blocks the pawn oops
stalemate the King can't move we messed
up okay yeah so well let's try this
though we're not done yet we said King
here right no wait a minute
King here we tried King to e6 and it
didn't work right
let's try King here see how that works
for us well he takes horizontal
opposition and he holds off and if he
goes if white goes up a square we go
back a square and if he goes back to f6
we take tagging opposition that we
repeat position white can't make headway
here's where the trick comes in this is
still winning position the correct move
is to sacrifice that protected past pawn
and then we grab the opposition and
force the King away from his pet from
his pawn on c6 so that's the trick who
would have thought you would give up
your protected past pawn see how we take
the opposition lateral opposition
forcing black to give way
and look we forced him away from the
pawn and we win the King and pawn and
beat so these King and pawn endings can
be tricky now I'm sure you guys
recognize this position three pawns
against three the Kings are off to the
side they have nothing to do with it
white can force through a passed pawn
and win the game what's the winning move
which one be six and if I take this way
what do you do
see six that's absolutely correct
if pawn takes the a pawn you take the b7
pawn and you get your queen and if I
take this pawn you push this one and you
got your queen okay now if I take this
way what's the winning move a six in
this case and it's very similar to the
last example and so it doesn't happen
very much but you would feel very
foolish if you had that position and you
didn't win it so put it in your bag of
tricks for endings
what's White's winning move you're
absolutely correct
that holds back the black pawn to the
third which is very important the six
row then the white King can come over
just two squares the pawn can advance
and the black King can get to the pawn
and two squares but if white plays his
cards right black I'll have to move away
from protecting the pawn so you got to
make the right follow up moves but - you
found the key move black goes here what
does white do King where
yeah either one now if black goes here
what's the winning move
King d7 right king d6 would be a gross
blunder because he can play King up and
white would have to get move away from
his pawn but you had the right move now
what's the winning move how about wait
wait wait wait here wait a minute wait
right here see he can't advance see if
if black could have gotten to the square
f5 protected the pawn and attacked the
white pawn and it was White's move white
would have to move away but because we
came here attacking the pawn and he had
to go here now he can't get to f5 and
our pawn covers f6 so he can't go there
we just go back here and he has to move
away from the pawn and we win but you're
right you could have moved the King up
and you would get back to the same kind
of position okay all right that's it for
the King and pawn it means now we still
have about 12 minutes so I'd like to go
into the two key critical positions on
rook and pawn endings because the author
says these these King and pawn endings
were fairly tricky wouldn't you say the
working pawn endings are even trickier
but there's some basic positions that
have been figured out that we can go
over that help understand it this is a
known drawing position determined by a
Frenchman from the seventeen hundred's
named Philidor who was a famous chess
player and there's an opening the
Philidor defense named after him but he
did his best work in chess in analyzing
simple endings like this
and he determined that even though white
is upon up if black can put his king and
rook in this position he can hold the
draw so let's talk about the position
notice that the king is directly in
front of the White Pass pawn that's
ideal you have to have the King almost
always has to be blocking the pond there
are a few exceptions where it can be a
draw off the Kings to the side but much
better to be in front now the other
thing is see how the rook is on the b6
score so that the white king cannot go
past the six row that keeps the the King
from coming up and threatening checkmate
against the black King which is already
on the eighth row now the other element
is to notice that the past pawn that
white has is the e pawn and that there
are three files to the right of the e
pawn right and there are four files to
the left it turns out it's only a draw
if the black rook is on the side of the
pawn that has more files if the black
work for let's say the white King was on
d5 and the white work was on a 7 and the
black work was on g6 black would lose
now the reason for that is it's
advantageous for the black work to be as
far away from the white King as possible
because let's say the King at some point
advances in front of the pawn goes to e5
there's a check and the King goes to e6
there's a check the King can go to d5 it
doesn't threaten the rook
you see that the rooks on the GB file
and the Kings on the D file if it was on
the short side of the passed pawn the
rook the King could move back and attack
the work and the work couldn't move away
from the king that makes all the
difference between winning and losing so
what you have to remember when you're
defending is your King has to be in
front of the pawn on the Queen Square
your work has to be on the six row but
has to be on the side of the pond that
has more files so that's the general
principle now let's walk through it the
only way white can advance is to move
his pawn up it's blacks move black stays
on the sixth foul he moves back and
forth between a six and B six until that
pawn advances to e6 when the pawn blocks
the effect of the rook and the white
king kin advanced to f6 okay so that's
why it's idea let's see what how black
defense moves this rook over pawn up he
moves his rook back pawn up if it was
White's move he would win the game by
moving his King to f6 threatening and
rook up checkmate and the black King
would have to move to the side and give
up blocking the pond but because it's
blacks move black can draw with what
move
what rook move can black draw with
the threat is king to f6 we need to be
able to check the king when it goes to
f6 how can we do that
work to be one that's absolutely right
and we harass the white king from the
back row and the King
notice that the pawn there's no squares
the King can't get between the black
king and the pawn so the black can check
forever and if the King moves away from
the pawn black moves through the earth
to e1 attacking the pawn forcing the
King back in and he can check so this is
a draw so let's go back in just once
again look at see the starting position
this is called philidor's drawing
position you have to know this to draw
and if you know this and you're a pawn
up you might be able to trick your
opponent if he doesn't play the exact
right sequence of moves now we have time
for the next critical position which is
a position where white wins okay this is
called lucina's winning position like
the other position it's a standard
position it was figured out by an
italian chess master back in the 1400s
or way long ago
anyway so it's surprising but the white
King has to be in front of the past pawn
blocking the queening square the pawn
has to be on the seventh rank and the
rook has to be preventing the black King
from approaching the pawn you get to
this position you have a winning
position for white it's called lucina's
winning position let's walk through it
real quickly
black moves he has to move along the the
rook file the H file if black or to move
here for example white can move his rook
and grab the file then he can move his
King over one square and force the pawn
to Queen with pawn to g8 and if black
King comes up it doesn't do him any good
cuz the white rook moves to f1 check
forcing the King away from the Queen
square so that's why black has to move
somewhere along the H file with his rook
now white moves to the fifth
ro ro very important he goes to the
fifth row because his plan is to bring
his King back he's going to check the
King make the King move two squares away
from the pawn he's going to bring his
King back to f7 the black shirts gonna
check him is going to move his King now
to g6 the rooks gonna check him but look
we have our work on the fifth row where
it can interpose between the king and
the black work blocking the check and
then our pawn can Queen the next move
remember the black King is two squares
away from the pawn and can't help and
the black rook can't stop and there's no
defense to pawn up so let's see how that
goes rook here check see the King is now
two squares away from the past pawn
can't help now we can move our King out
from behind the pawn the white king
check here check
they call this maneuver where you move
the rook to the fifth row and then block
the check that's called building a
bridge and that's the key to winning
many many many rook and pawn endings
where you're a pawn up you have to know
that technique or it'll be a draw so
that'll be enough for tonight thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]